Oh
I believe the two causes that I believe
of the most in our equality and justice
and whatever I interpret that to be per
day you know it could be something as
simple as oh it sucks that this girl in
Mississippi couldn't take her girlfriend
to prom and I'll write about that in
fact constance mcmillen I wrote about
that story on my website a lot and I had
the opportunity to invite her to my
birthday party and I thought that'd be a
little bit cooler than even going to
prom because she got to meet a lot of
cool celebrities and have a fun time in
Los Angeles
absolutely it affects it in a positive
way for example one of the prop 8
protests I helped organize a lot of
celebrities gathering together to lend
their fame to the cause I still remember
it you know I got Kelly Osbourne to show
up I got pd when's to show up mark
hoppus emmy rossum eliza dushku a lot of
people that I know because I live in
Hollywood and have relationships with
these folks they came up they came out
we all met up together we all marched
and that was a great thing because their
celebrity you helped you know they've
got their pictures taken it ran in
magazines and it further along the
conversation
I have no desire to be a serious
mainstream journalists or commentator in
fact I don't take myself seriously I
take what I do seriously but myself I
just like to have fun which is great and
it's one of the reasons why I can do a
lot of different things